When you start thinking about Alexa and
all these other things,
one of the things that my career has
been completely predicated on is the
fact that I am willing to take chances
on things that aren't mainstream yet
because I understand that if I go after
social code and I,
if I go after vine and if I go after
Mick Mack and if I go after Yak and all,
if I go after all these things that I
only need one of those seven to actually
hit snapchat,
instagram to win that bet.
We have enormous fear in this room to I
have to wait or let's wait to it's big
or what if I waste my time right?
Will I waste my time on these platforms
if it doesn't become big?
And so one of the other themes that I
really wanted to leave here with
tonight,
knowing the demo of this room is we have
to have a lot more risk tolerance on new
platforms.
If you're not playing back to details
that I know you're taking notes.
If you're not playing with Marco Polo
and afterschool and House party,
then you're not there potentially at the
platforms.
That can become the next things at the
top of our tongue.
How many people here?
Let's be really honest.
Let's be really,
really,
really honest with ourselves.
Inbound,
please raise your hand if this is true.
How many people in this room,
and I want everybody look around,
said two and a half years ago,
three years ago,
maybe even a year ago,
that they would never be on snapchat.
That was stupid and now have a snapchat
account.
Raise your hands,
raise it high,
higher this.
This is where all the action is.
This is the opportunity in this room,
but we continue to downplay.
We continue to downplay the upside
because we feared the risk of being on
there and wasting time.
If you have not achieved what you want
to professionally or in life,
time is the number one thing you've got.
You need to deploy as much of that as
humanly possible.
That is the asset when you have not
achieved the things that you want to
happen in life,
and it is because of time that you ever
wanted to put into these platforms and
worlds.
That is a massive mistake.
It's the one asset you have.
Not Everybody in this room has money.
It's true.
You agree?
Right?
So are you going to work in fucking face
off?
Thank you.
It's the one thing we have.
It's the one thing we have because
everybody wants to come up with excuses.
I'd spend my life reading excuses on
social media and my inbox of this.
I wasn't born that way.
I wasn't born here.
This,
I'm a female,
I'm an immigrant,
I'm a minority.
I'm a transgender ix excuses reality.
By the way,
I truly believe those are disadvantages.
I'm not naive to the shortcomings of
this country.
The problem is nobody cares.
The market doesn't care.
So we sit and we dwell and if so,
what do you think we've been doing for
the last month and what we're going to
do morning,
we're going to dwell and complain and
that's utter defense instead of going on
the office.
And so we spend unbelievable amounts of
time dwelling and wasting our time on
dumb shit.
Like peop.
People literally email me and say,
you're so lucky and I wish this was
happening to me.
And then the third tweet or the third
instagram post is awesome.
Saturday stayed home and watched and
tighter season of fucking game of
thrones.
Yeah.
We need to start understanding how big
this opportunity is because it's for
everybody in this room.
You will sit back in 2030 years and
regret if you didn't execute in this
era.
And by the way,
I don't want to hear that this is for 20
and 30 year olds,
40 50 60 70 it's an equal playing field.
If you're willing to be a practitioner
and understand the ecosystem that I've
been speaking about tonight,
there's never been a better time.
Look,
it's very obvious,
these kind of characters.
There was no respect for 20 year olds in
the business world 20 years ago when I
came out.
But now because of technology,
there's a lot of organizations that
apple solutely respect 20 and 30 year
olds.
Also,
what is happening is I'm spending so
much time with 40 to 60 year old
executives who are dwelling and are
upset and tell me dumb shit like Gary,
I didn't grow up with this shit.
Neither did I.
Alice
I was 20 before I even was on a
computer.
I think grow up with this shit.
I figured it out and so I sit there and
see completely capable operators that
have made it happen for the last 2030
years being crippled by,
I don't understand how snapchat works.
It's so confusing.
Were just filled with excuses.
We are,
people are just losing their hunger and
then,
and then by the way,
let me get really mad for two seconds
with my fancy rich friends.
The thing that I'm completely blown away
by that I had no idea was going on in
capitalism and meritocracy is once you
get rich,
you actually try to spend your dollars
to create laws that allow you not to
work and still hold onto your money.
100% right?
I mean I'm blown away by this.
You were benefit,
you were benefited because in your
twenties to 60 for 40 years you grinded
and out executed somebody and you were
able to make lots of money.
But now that you're tired and you're
finished and you're older and don't want
to put in the work,
you don't want the next young buck to
come along and eat your lunch.
That's not how capitalism works.
True.
It's just not.
And so we have all these trends and we
have the great fortune of living in an
era where things have been really good
for a very long time.
And so I walk around the world and I
told my wife,
Lizzie,
I'm like Lizzie,
listen to me.
I don't care clearly cause I was such a
shit student with the kids do with
school.
But please,
they can't be in programs where we give
away seventh place trophies.
I have no idea who wins the election
tonight,
but we need to fucking band seventh
place trophies and America.
So we have all these macro situations
going on and not to mention for a lot of
people here are under 30 you haven't
been in the game during an economic
downturn because things have been very
cushy for the last seven years where if
you're 23 years old and you have an
idea,
your company's miraculously worth $4
million.
And so we're living in a very intriguing
time and I think that the passion and he
anx and the energy that I bring tonight
are predicated on a couple of tried and
true things.
Number one,
if you're not making longterm decisions,
you will be vulnerable.
The market's changing very quickly and
anybody who's looking for short term
stuff gets short term stuff and then
gets hurt in the long term.
Things like Airbnb,
guys,
airbnb shouldn't have been invented by
Brian and Joe.
Airbnb should have been invented by
Merriot.
But merriot is looking short term and
isn't creating business models to put
themselves out of business.
Uber should have not been created by
Garrett and they shouldn't.
They should have not been created by
Garrett and Travis.
They should have been created by the guy
or girl that owned the most medallions
in New York City or by Grey Hound.
If you sit here tonight and you're doing
well,
you're in danger because there's
somebody young and hungry that has the
Internet,
which is a platform that creates a zero
cost to get into the game that's coming
after your shit.
So if you don't do what I do,
which is wake up every single morning,
every single morning and try to put
yourself out of business,
somebody else is gonna do it for you.
It is much more fun,
my friends,
to put yourself out of business than
have somebody else do it for you.
And so please,
if your cushy who's cushy,
raise your hand if shit's going real
well.
Jesus Christ.
Three people raise their hand.
I think you need to shut down this
fucking,
you don't.
Good.
Awesome.
What was that?
I was like,
you're doing good.
You're like,
yeah,
we're doing okay.
You know,
he always,
so you've got to understand.
The only thing that's interesting to me,
and the only thing I have,
I always say that basically my career is
predicated much more similar to Mariano
Rivera than anything else that I can
think of.
If you're a baseball fan.
He was a very good closer for the New
York Yankees where basically his entire
career was predicated on one pitch.
He had one pitch for 17 years and nobody
could hit it,
and that's basically my business career.
I've got one pitch,
which is the following.
I know what you're going to do before
you know you're going to do it.
It's the thing that I was gifted with.
Just like if you can sing just like it's
you.
I've always had the intuition I was made
fun of and aggressively made fun of for
launching a website in 1996 because just
like people sit here and think that vine
or snapchat is a fad.
There's people in this room that
remember where the whole Internet was a
fad,
but I bet on it and I built a big
business and then I was made fun of
because this thing called Youtube came
out and I took a chance on that cause I
thought it was going to be big and
started a wine show in Santa in front of
a camera and drank four bottles of wine
for 20 minutes and hundreds of thousands
of people watched it
and then that worked and then twitter
worked and then I invested in twitter
and facebook and things of that nature.
But I had so many losses along the way.
One thing that's never talked about with
my genius career was that I was on
youtube super early,
but I left six months in and started
producing wine library TV exclusively on
viddler.
I was wrong.
One thing that's not talked about is
that I thought that the biggest startup
in the world in 2010 was going to be Yo
Bango.
I was wrong
and I continue to be interested in being
wrong for the rest of my life because I
am a pure bred entrepreneur because I'm
not scared of trying things and wasting
my valuable time because I want things
and most of all,
and this is the most of all the whole
thing.
I just genuinely don't give a fuck about
what you think about me
balanced with,
I really care about what everybody says
about me
and in that friction,
I mean that you have to deploy real ego
and real humility around this course
because we live in that world.
But if I could inspire anything in the
time that I was here today,
it's very simply this,
please do me one favor.
I'm going to wrap it up with this and
this matters so much to me.
Please,
whatever it takes,
call your grandmother,
go to your great grandfather's burial
spot.
Go back to the old country,
go to a shelter,
do something,
do something that recalibrates your
perspective on what is actually going on
here.
We have never had it better.
My friends.
I'm going to leave you with a very
interesting data point.
You guys like data.
Who likes data?
Great.
Let me give you some fucking data.
More people in America will die from a
coconut falling out of a tree and
hitting you on the head and killing you.
Then terrorism.
Yeah,
I see you tentative like is he fucking
serious?
I'm dead fucking serious.
Kids seven to 11 watch more twitch east
sports than all the four major sports
combined.
That's data we are living through a
totally different type of 10 years ago,
the weirdest thing in the world was your
friend dated people online.
Now every single person's swipes to the
left and right,
24 seven
and so the trends and our society have
changed and either you're going to sit
here and binary.
This is a black and white conversation.
Either you're going to leave here and
understand how fucking awesome it is and
you're going to take full advantage of
it and be a winner or you're going to
sit and dwell on all the negatives of it
and be a losing player.
It's just the truth.
It's not complicated.
It's not fun for me to say,
I don't want you to lose.
I desperately want you to win,
but this is on you.
Nobody else is in control.
There are people who deal with things
like the loss of their children or real
diseases.
We're sitting in dwelling about not
getting enough likes on fucking
instagram.
We're sitting in dwelling about forces
that don't really have impact on us.
It is time that this collective room and
our space understands.
This is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life.
And you're really,
and I mean really need to fucking grab
it.
Thank you.